My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我叫Yana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容让我觉得非常有趣。我惊讶于通往这一职业的道路竟有如此之多，而且并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我感到自信，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的心理压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. Have you ever felt like you were the problem? Not just that you made a mistake, but that you were fundamentally flawed. That sinking feeling, the urge to hide, that voice in your head saying, if people really knew me, they'd walk away. That's shame and it runs deeper than fear, guilt or embarrassment. It can shape our sense of self, our relationships and even our careers. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist and if any of that resonated you're in the right place.
但请相信我，一旦开始阅读，你就停不下来。你是否曾觉得自己就是那个“问题所在”？不仅仅是犯了错，而是从根本上就有缺陷？那种下沉的感觉、想要躲藏的冲动，脑海中那个声音在说：“如果人们真正了解我，他们就会离开。”这就是羞耻感，它比恐惧、内疚或尴尬更深层。它会塑造我们的自我意识、人际关系，甚至我们的职业生涯。我是Marianne博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，如果这些话引起了你的共鸣，那么你来对地方了。
Let's talk about shame and like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along and thank you for being here so shame can show up in a variety of ways and keep us from fulfilling what might be our full potential. You might be watching this because you yourself are struggling with shame or because someone that you care about is or maybe even someone that you're working with clinically might be too. And in today's episode, we're going to be looking at what shame is, how it shows up in our lives, and what influence it can have on ourselves and those around us too. What is shame?
让我们来谈谈羞耻感，记得点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎大家，感谢你们的到来。羞耻感会以多种方式表现出来，阻碍我们发挥全部潜能。你观看此视频可能是因为你自己正在与羞耻感作斗争，或者你关心的人正在经历，又或者你在临床工作中接触的人也可能如此。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨什么是羞耻感，它如何在我们的生活中显现，以及它对我们自己和周围的人有什么影响。什么是羞耻感？
Shame is an intense emotion that makes us feel like there's something wrong with us at our very core. Unlike guilt, which is about feeling bad for something we've done, shame is about feeling bad for who we are. It tells us we're unworthy, unlovable or flawed. There can be a really nice way of thinking about what shame is and how to separate it from guilt. So shame is like a focus on the self. So that's like I am bad. Whereas guilt will focus on behaviour like I did something bad. Shame, importantly, is often invisible.
羞耻感是一种强烈的情绪，让我们觉得自己在核心本质上出了问题。与内疚不同——内疚是为我们所做的事情感到难过——羞耻感是为“我们是谁”而感到难过。它告诉我们自己是不值得的、不可爱的或有缺陷的。有一种很好的方式来思考什么是羞耻感以及如何将其与内疚区分开来：羞耻感关注的是自我，即“我很糟糕”；而内疚关注的是行为，即“我做了一件坏事”。重要的是，羞耻感往往是隐形的。
People might not even be able to name it or kind of get a sense of it. But that doesn't mean that its effects can't still be felt really deeply. ground calls shame, the intensely painful feeling or experience of believing that we are flawed and therefore unworthy of love and belonging. So let's take a look. Where does shame come from? It can often develop from childhood. It's about the way that we've been reared and those experiences that we've had when we've done certain things in our lives. They might result from things such as critical or shaming parental style. experiences of neglect or abuse having been bullied rejected or isolated messages from
人们甚至可能无法命名它或察觉到它。但这并不意味着它的影响不能被深刻地感受到。布琳·布朗将羞耻感定义为一种极其痛苦的感觉或体验，即相信我们是有缺陷的，因此不配得到爱和归属感。那么，让我们来看看羞耻感从何而来？它通常源于童年。它与我们的成长方式以及我们在生活中经历的某些事情有关。它们可能源于批评性或羞辱性的教养方式、忽视或虐待的经历、被欺凌、被拒绝或被孤立，以及来自……
school religion or society about what is acceptable and what is not experiences of racism homophobia abelism or other marginalisation even as adults like we can be really well meaning but accidentally shame people with the language choices that we use that might look like you should be ashamed of yourself don't be silly stop crying your being a baby. Shame can also develop in later life, especially after trauma, rejection, failure or having been humiliated. When I was on LinkedIn the other day, I saw a really powerful post where someone had been talking about their experiences on graduation and where they had worn an outfit that they wanted to feel really excited and proud about. So they'd worn a dress,
学校、宗教或社会关于什么是可接受、什么是不可接受的信息。种族主义、恐同、能力歧视或其他边缘化的经历。即使作为成年人，我们可能出于好意，但却无意中用我们的语言选择羞辱了他人，比如：“你应该为自己感到羞耻”、“别傻了”、“别哭了，你像个孩子一样”。羞耻感也可能在以后的生活中产生，特别是在创伤、拒绝、失败或受辱之后。前几天我在LinkedIn上看到一篇非常有力的文章，有人谈到了他们毕业时的经历，当时他们穿了一套自己感到非常兴奋和自豪的衣服。他们穿了一件裙子，
probably quite similar to the dress I'm wearing now, with their arms out and showing their legs. And somebody had said to them, well, don't you feel ashamed having your body out like that? And that had made her think, actually, no, I don't. You know, this is who I am. This is my authentic self. And it had made her think about whether she still wanted to be part of the religion that she had been raised in. So that gives a really nice flavour, a really nice example of how shame can be kind of layered upon us and then reinforced over time by the people around us. But of course we get choices. Once we get to be grown-ups, we can choose to do something differently. And more of that will be coming up in episode two about what to do about shame. Today
可能和我现在穿的这件很像，露着手臂和腿。有人对她说：“你这样露着身体，难道不觉得羞耻吗？”这让她反思：“其实，我不觉得。”你知道，这就是我，这是真实的自我。这让她思考是否还想继续留在她从小长大的宗教中。这提供了一个很好的视角，一个很好的例子，说明羞耻感是如何被层层叠加在我们身上，并随着时间的推移被周围的人所强化的。但当然，我们有选择权。一旦我们成年，我们可以选择做些不同的事情。关于如何应对羞耻感，更多内容将在第二集中讨论。今天，
we're taking a really deep dive and unpacking what it is. So how does shame affect us? Oh, shame can be tricky. It can be the master of disguise and it can show up in so many ways, including people pleasing, perfectionism, avoidance, self-criticism, substance use or addictive behaviours, disconnection from others, bodily shame or low self-esteem. And it's important to remember that shame thrives in secrecy. When we avoid speaking out loud about shame, that is firmly keeping shame in the driver's seat and in control. I thought it might be really nice to look at a couple of case studies so that we can really illuminate how and why shame shows up for people. Firstly, let's meet James. James is a 36-year-old teacher and he recently found out
我们正在深入探讨并剖析它到底是什么。那么羞耻感如何影响我们？哦，羞耻感可能很棘手。它是伪装大师，可以以多种方式表现出来，包括讨好他人、完美主义、回避、自我批评、药物滥用或成瘾行为、与他人疏离、身体羞耻或低自尊。记住，羞耻感在秘密中滋生，这一点很重要。当我们避免大声谈论羞耻感时，就是让羞耻感牢牢占据主导地位并掌控一切。我想看几个案例研究，这样我们就能真正阐明羞耻感为何以及如何出现在人们身上。首先，让我们认识一下James。James是一位36岁的老师，他最近发现……
that his long-term partner had cheated on him. Rationally, he knew that it wasn't his fault, but the shame hit hard. His internal thoughts were those like, I must be boring. I'm not a Everyone's going to think I'm pathetic, maybe I'm not good enough in bed. He has been withdrawing from his friends, keeping himself busy at work and telling himself to get over it, stop being stupid, man up, all those kind of things. But the shame stays under the surface, unspoken and feels so heavy. Let's now check in with Amina. Amina is an assistant psychologist who applied for training but didn't get in this year.
他的长期伴侣背叛了他。从理性上讲，他知道这不是他的错，但羞耻感却重重地打击了他。他内心的想法是：“我一定很无聊”、“我不是一个……每个人都会觉得我很可怜，也许我在床上不够好。”他开始疏远朋友，让自己忙于工作，并告诉自己“克服它”、“别傻了”、“像个男人一样”，诸如此类。但羞耻感仍潜伏在表面之下，无法言说，感觉如此沉重。现在让我们看看Amina。Amina是一位助理心理学家，她申请了培训但今年没被录取。
Although she has had excellent feedback from her supervisors over the years, and she rationally knows how competitive this process is, she feels crushed. And inside her thoughts are spiraling, I'm not good enough, I should have done better, everyone else is progressing and I'm being left behind, everyone will know that I'm not good enough. She starts avoiding professional spaces online, she doesn't tell her friends what's happening, she feels alone and ashamed. This isn't guilt, Amina didn't do anything wrong, but she feels like she is wrong, like her worth is in question. So why does shame matter? So shame isn't
尽管多年来她从主管那里得到了极好的反馈，并且理性上知道这个过程竞争有多激烈，但她感到崩溃。她内心的想法在盘旋：“我不够好”、“我本应该做得更好”、“其他人都在进步，而我被抛在后面了”、“每个人都会知道我不够好”。她开始回避线上的专业空间，不告诉朋友发生了什么，感到孤独和羞耻。这不是内疚，Amina没有做错任何事，但她觉得“自己”错了，仿佛她的价值受到了质疑。那么，为什么羞耻感很重要？因为羞耻感不仅仅是……
just an emotional experience. It can affect all aspects of our life, including our behaviour, our relationships and of course our mental health. It can be linked to depression, anxiety, PTSD, disorder eating and low self-esteem. In career situations, It can cause paralysis around applying for roles or courses, putting ourselves forward, avoidance of feedback, and of course, burnout from overworking to prove our worth. Shame can affect everyone, and it can hold us back. It can make us feel like we are missing the opportunities like they're passing us by because we think we're not good enough for them or that we're somehow internally flawed. The importance of naming shame. Shame is powerful, but it does lose its power when we speak about it.
一种情感体验。它会影响我们生活的方方面面，包括我们的行为、人际关系，当然还有我们的心理健康。它可能与抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、饮食失调和低自尊有关。在职业生涯中，它可能导致在申请职位或课程、展示自我时出现瘫痪，回避反馈，当然，还有因过度工作以证明自身价值而导致的倦怠。羞耻感会影响每个人，它会阻碍我们前进。它让我们觉得自己在错过机会，仿佛机会正在溜走，因为我们认为自己不够好，或者在某种程度上内在有缺陷。命名羞耻感的重要性：羞耻感很强大，但当我们谈论它时，它就会失去力量。
This episode is your invitation to recognise your shame, understand its roots, know that you're not alone, and begin to move from shame to self-compassion. We're going to be exploring more of that in this sister episode on what to do about shame and how to treat it. In the meantime, I'd like you to reflect on a few things. Where does shame show up in your life? What stories does shame tell you about yourself? And whose voice might that shame voice be using? If you find yourself in the position of either James or Amina or someone entirely different, please know that things can change that you can feel differently and that treatment is available.
这一集邀请你识别自己的羞耻感，了解它的根源，知道你并不孤单，并开始从羞耻感转向自我同情。我们将在关于如何应对和治疗羞耻感的姊妹篇中探讨更多内容。在此期间，我希望你反思几件事：羞耻感出现在你生活的哪些方面？羞耻感向你讲述了关于你自己的什么故事？那个羞耻的声音可能在模仿谁的声音？如果你发现自己处于James或Amina的位置，或者完全不同的境地，请知道事情是可以改变的，你可以有不同的感受，而且治疗方法是可行的。
If you need advice or support, please check out the details on the screen or in the show notes. I think it would be disingenuous of me to not share. my own experiences of shame, not feeling like I was good enough. Even when I was starting out to write the grief collective book, for example, I had this sense of, oh, what my others say, you know, maybe I'm not good enough to be doing this. Maybe I shouldn't be doing it. You know, maybe I'm not the right person to be doing this.
如果你需要建议或支持，请查看屏幕上或节目说明中的详细信息。我觉得如果不分享我自己的羞耻感经历——那种觉得自己不够好的感觉——是不真诚的。例如，即使在我开始写《悲伤合集》这本书时，我也有这种感觉：“哦，别人会怎么说？你知道，也许我没有能力做这件事。也许我不应该做。你知道，也许我不是做这件事的合适人选。”
And the same with the Our Tricky Brain Kit. You know, oh, dear, like, oh, you know, little old me, I'm not good enough to do this. but we've really got to be able to tune in to the things we're saying about ourselves. And we're just going to be just a little bit curious. Maybe that's not true, you know? So there's more coming on what to do about shame in future. But please know that you're not alone in this,
《我们棘手的大脑工具包》也是如此。你知道，“哦，天哪，像我这样的小人物，我没有能力做这件事。”但我们必须能够调频到我们对自己所说的话上。我们只需要保持一点点好奇心。也许那不是真的，你知道吗？所以未来会有更多关于如何应对羞耻感的内容。但请知道，在这件事上你并不孤单，
and it affects all of us in all walks of life. If you're watching this because you're an aspiring psychologist, please do check out the aspiring psychologist membership run by me. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next day, in a more intensive way where you'd like to see me 12 times in a year one to one, then ready to rise is for you. Let's really take this shame, turn it on its head, you know, explode it out of the water and get you to your full potential. Yes, that you're sad to be on your way to being qualified Yes, my name is Veronica Kassova.
它影响着各行各业的我们所有人。如果你观看此视频是因为你是一位有抱负的心理学家，请务必查看由我运营的“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”。如果时机成熟，你准备好以更深入的方式进入下一阶段，希望在一年内与我进行12次一对一交流，那么“准备崛起”计划非常适合你。让我们真正地面对这种羞耻感，彻底扭转它，你知道，把它彻底粉碎，让你发挥出全部潜能。是的，你正在成为合格心理学家的路上。是的，我的名字是Veronica Kassova。
I live in Edinburgh and Trent. I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover.
我住在爱丁堡。我刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在LinkedIn上建立人脉时，Marian向我推荐了《临床心理学家合集》，我必须说我非常喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，让我们窥见那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙事才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。
A common thread in the stories I valued most. was to be compassionate not only with others, but with myself too. Also, not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, grow, and the final results will come as a by-product. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我最看重的故事中有一个共同点：不仅要对他人的富有同情心，也要对自己富有同情心。此外，不要执着于成为心理学家，而是享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。Marian，感谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。